people where a war comes to their
doorstep and on monday there were the
postman and on tuesday they're a
militant the same thing happened in
syria you know the same thing happens in
palestine the same thing that happens in
afghanistan these people all have lives
these people all have aspirations dreams
they're normal people
jake hanrahan welcome to the show thanks
very much mate thanks for having me you
are recently back from ukraine you left
the day before everything started but
that you didn't mean for that to happen
that was just uh fortunate timing i
guess i mean it was kind of i think it
was like two days actually but it was it
was one of these things where
you know me and the guy was working with
my mate johnny pickup we were there we
were like shall we stay it's probably
not going to happen you know because it
just i don't know it was it just seemed
almost inconceivable i don't know why
but it did at the time we had we we've
been filming anyway we've been filming
with like the training the militia
training so it's like we had a good film
anyway um which read it in now
and i was like you know what i've got
things to do i've got family commitments
he's the same we said all right we'll go
back and then you know two days into the
edit i get a call in the morning like
they've done it they've invaded it's
like wow jesus why did you think it
wasn't gonna happen
honestly it was i think maybe the mood
in kiev you know like like four days
before the invasion we were out chatting
to people at the pub you know stuff like
that you know local ukrainians in kiev
and they were like no there's no way
like it's not gonna happen the
government wasn't really preparing bomb
shelters like i know that you know biden
said it's gonna happen and then all
these other intelligence agencies did
but they said it was gonna be on this
day then this day then this day and i
think the enormity of it just you know
naively perhaps i a lot where i wasn't
just me a lot of people just thought no
probably not gonna happen like that
probably just the east but lo and behold
you know he went in uh you know full
pelt
what is it like then i know that you've
been back since this fighting's fully
started but you are you've got popular
front which is your
organization conflict reporting
independent journalism and stuff and you
guys are putting out an unbelievable
amount of videos footage you've got
friends you've literally we've had to
delay recording because one of your
friends has rang from kiev to say that
there's been some heavy bombing going on
can you try and explain to people
what life is like for civilians in
ukraine at the moment
yeah yeah i mean i think that's a good
question because there's a lot of focus
on the west kind of
lording up this and lording up that or
then it's like online political people
screaming that their ideology isn't
being appeased the reality is people on
the ground civilians you know like
you've just said are living in bomb
shelters there are people like the i saw
some photos earlier there's like a
makeshift hospital um in in in one of
the you know in the in one of the
basements there were children with
cancer you know under bombardment now
like getting treatment in a basement
best they can a little girl a
six-year-old girl was killed um the
other day
uh rocket landed near a supermarket and
she was killed um the photos are just
just horrific like there was a you know
a photojournalist just happened to be
with his family and they're rushing her
into the hospital and she just dies on
the bed the mother's just there like
crying you know it's absolutely brutal
and there's a lot of political
kind of nonsense going on and i really
think that the focus it's like yeah well
civilians are dying right now i think
it's around 135
civilians have been killed in one week
um 13 of those were children 400 people
civilians wounded around 1 000 to 2 000
fighters on each side killed um it's one
week in it's madness you know it's very
very serious very brutal and russia is
no matter which way you're painting it
they they are indiscriminately hit in
civilian areas right now you know
they're bombing apartment blocks um like
like you just said um a bomb just went
off or a rocket here i should say um
near the near the one of the train
stations the train stations the subway
system is where everybody goes for the
bomb shelters like what what strategic
target possibly could that be i don't
know but it does seem to be like you
know they're going after civilians we've
seen them do the same thing in syria not
to say that the west doesn't do the
exact same thing um everybody wants to
do this that and the other like oh what
about what about it's like yes yes very
seriously i mean like two months ago
america wiped out a whole civilian
family enough in afghanistan as they
were leaving and just were like toodaloo
no one was charged nothing happened
awful but right now you know we're
talking about ukraine yeah it's like
yeah civilians are getting bombed left
and right it's really bad i think food's
running out well i should say like sorry
yeah the the food is running out as well
in medicines as well i just spoke to a
friend and she's like my grandma she's
in her cube she's she's 95 her medicine
is going to run out in a couple days
like what can we do it's just it's so
brutal man
are there no rules i don't understand
whatever is the rules of engagement
uh around the sort of targets that you
can hit if you decide to invade a
country are you just allowed to
indiscriminately
target
um missiles wherever you want
i mean you know there is there is the
geneva convention and you know war
crimes but essentially
it doesn't that doesn't really exist you
know what i mean no one sticks to it
right i don't know i don't know what you
mean
so i mean um you know i mean there's an
is an example of like nato you know
there is um a few years ago there's
videos of turkish soldiers um murdering
prisoners of war there's a video of them
like holding a beheaded you know the
prisoner of war they're holding the head
that's a nate that's nato's second
largest army there wasn't even an
investigation you know like nato's kind
of just poo poo it oh it's kurdish
rebels don't worry about it sort of
thing so you know again another incident
um turkey burned a load of civilians to
death in a basement
in a town called gizra in southeast
turkey in 2016. and you know nothing
really happened you know so it's it's
you know it's it's very
the west is is very firmly on their high
horse right now but you know there is no
real rules let's be honest there is
you know the concept of war crime i'm
not saying that we should ignore it of
course not it's brutal it's disgusting
but at the end of the day when war
happens a lot of the rules go clean out
the window you know what i mean it's
just it's unfortunately the way it is
things get very primitive
and very nasty things happen you know
and russia has just said you know we're
going to just do this i guess not that
they're justified at all i think it's
absolutely horrendous and above whenever
civilians are targeted like it's just
disgusting um and i think in in terms of
like i don't know about legal laws but
like natural law it's just like
horrendous you know what i mean if
there's a hell you know those people
deserve to go there but it's yeah when
you're talking about rules of engagement
it gets very flimsy when the war starts
you know what i'm saying yeah that makes
sense you said that you were in town
whatever in the pub four days before
most of the people that were there that
were civilians that are now facing the
potential of being hit with missiles
basically didn't think that it was going
to happen it seemed like the government
didn't think it was going to happen does
that mean that in terms of provisions
protection preparation
there's there's
um it's insubstantial
yes definitely yeah that's that is true
i mean
don't give i'm not knocking zielinski
he's really risen to the kind of the
occasion you know he's definitely i i
respect that he's staying with the
people there he's in kiev it's it's you
know the us offered to take him you know
to take him out like we'll get you away
he said no he's staying here like fair
play to him but there's a lot being
ignored here while people are loading up
zolensky there's a lot being ignored the
fact that the bomb shelters weren't
properly readied we interviewed a lad a
very good local reporter in kiev who the
week before had gone around to all the
bomb shelters that the government had
designated
some of them like there was padlocks on
them and it had a number call this
number he called the number and the
woman was like i don't know what
everybody's ringing me there is no key
you know things like that there's not
enough food provisions so whilst whilst
on one degree it's like yeah okay
zielinski's doing his thing now i do
start to think like what was happening
before that you know like why wasn't
there more preparations it's not for me
to say maybe but i think it's worth
looking at you know essentially in the
long run but right now i guess that is
not really in or there it's happened and
this is what's happening now but yeah i
would agree that it it seemed to me
anyway and we spoke to a lot of people
you know covered a lot of things and um
it it didn't yeah it didn't look like
there was proper preparations you know
we went to there was one place it was a
bomb shelter but it was also a strip
club you know it was used as a strip
club because you know no one's had to
use the bomb shelter and that's fine you
know whatever it was kind of funny but
at the end of the day it's like well
shouldn't shouldn't that be gutted and
turned into you know there was no
preparations there there wasn't stacks
of food there wasn't heating there
wasn't blankets that you know what i
mean it's that's not that's not really
preparation they just sprayed a thing on
the wall saying bomb shelter in case of
emergency or something like that and
it's like that's not really preparation
you know what i mean um so yeah i
definitely think you know there's that
could have been done more but again
there's a massive subway system in kiev
especially and across ukraine so you
know i know that a lot of people are
down there but yeah it's it's very it's
looking bad what would you say
uh how would you say that the russian
offensive's gone so far do you reckon
that they expect it to be further along
than this by this point
yeah i mean i'll be honest i'm kind of
you know through and through a reporter
on the ground i don't really look too
much into the kind of analysis and that
because i've seen things happen at war
where it's like you know 50 000 analysts
are telling you this and you get there
and you're like oh this is not at all
what it is you know not to disrespect
them but it's quite easy to do an
analysis from the desk but i will say
that i do think that
russia the signs you can see that russia
perhaps expected it to go quicker than
this is the um
i can't remember the exact one but
russia basically and putin i should say
um sacked one of his like head kind of
commanders you know what i mean replaced
him quite early on i think like the
fourth day of the invasion so i think
that gives you a sign that
something and you know some it's not
right here something it's not really
going the way they did and honestly you
know
the
it's the ukrainian resistance is very
real you know what i mean i've been back
and forth to ukraine i think almost 10
times uh since i was 27 so i'm 32 now
you know a couple years a little while
i've been back and forth to the front
lines all over the place
the culture they have there is one of
resistance you know it's very
i mean you just have to look at the
amount of people joining the citizens of
militias every every people i'm talking
to friends they're like reporters and
i'm like oh how's the fix you're working
with and they're like oh he's gone he
joined the resistance you know what i
mean like there's a lot of people
there's mechanics there's metal workers
are making big what they call hedgehogs
like big kind of spiked metal things to
put in the road to try and deter tanks
or armored vehicles everyone is doing
their bit you know
there's
um i think we spoke to a lad yesterday
and he was saying that there was like um
well we did speak to a lad yesterday but
he was saying that there was like a
guy that was a roofer just preparing
molotovs you know you know just for
everybody in the street you know it's
it's everyone has kind of come together
and there is like a real resistance
which is commendable i think anyone
that's been invaded by by a country and
they're a sovereign state and whatever
like fair play they can resist is
absolutely their their progress to do so
but i don't think they can resist
completely you know i think kiev is
going to fall unfortunately it will take
longer than russia expected and it has
been a bit of a meat grinder you know
the ukraine military are really a lot
more prepared a lot more powerful than
they were um in 2014 after the
revolution when you know russia annex
crimea and the fighting started in the
east of ukraine but but the the problem
is like russia is an incredibly powerful
military you know and they have you know
ukraine is completely outgunned um and
russia has already shown that they will
do
they will go all the way in terms of we
will just bomb civilians we will just do
that you know what i'm saying so i think
that's a worry however i will say that
once they do start taking major cities
the guerrilla warfare will start and
that will be hell for the russians i
really believe that not on any kind of
romantic level just as a as an
observation of i've covered a lot of how
what do you mean well it's you know if
you've got like a united people i mean
you've got people there's militias from
all different backgrounds there
unfortunately there's like far-right
militias but there's also jewish
militias there's chechen militias russia
um
bella russian militias there's an
anti-fascist militia right now that is
just gathering steam so everybody is
coming together and are like right we're
fighting we're not having and they're
going side by side so you would have
potentially a jewish militia and a
nazi militia fighting shield at your
shoulder potentially you could it's
happened before yeah it's happened
before it's it's a weird situation and
it's one that people jump on but
i've seen weirder things happen in war
you know what i mean like i said a lot
of the rules go out the window all of
the internet analysis is irrelevant
completely you know what i'm saying not
that you know i mean the the far-right
element is horrific i think it's awful
but it is it's not you know i mean the
president is jewish he was voted in with
a 73 majority at the same time that the
far-right parties formed a coalition for
that election they got less than three
percent of the vote so the idea that the
whole country is an artsy is not true
but the idea that you know the nazi
element is propaganda is also not true
it is a serious problem but like i said
it's it's there's a very it's a very
diverse country there's 44 million
people live there it's huge there's
there's people from all over the place
um
but you know it it's it's it's the
guerrilla warfare element of it i think
will really will really see that if they
start taking big cities because yeah a
lot of the the you know citizen militias
will probably go i didn't sign up for
this i'm leaving actually but a lot
won't a lot will go to ground and
they'll
set bombs and they'll you know you know
they'll start doing assassinations um
not because you know ukrainians are
special that's just how it happens you
know i've seen it in so many different
countries and when you have like a unit
of people like that that are well armed
i think ukraine is this 22nd
most armed country on earth
you know it's they're not just going
there's only 44 million people there
yeah and there's a lot of guns you know
i mean a lot of weapons are coming in
from the west um
and they'll make their own stuff they
already are you know and they're already
a lot of these people are war veterans
anyway you know they're primed for this
they're ready so i think you're going to
see
unfortunately like really horrific you
know brutality
but again it's it's war you know what i
mean and if someone comes in and takes
their city who's to tell them they're
not allowed to resist that in any way
possible you know what i mean how much
of this because you've you've kind of
identified that uh when an invasion
begins this sort of more primitive
primal
um
demeanor takes over the people that are
being invaded
but it seems to me like
the ukrainian response has been pretty
intense you know i've seen alexander
usic
in full military gear yeah yeah i've
seen uh vladimir lomachenko
one of my favorite boxers unbelievable
boxer i mean i wouldn't want to get in a
handheld comeback with him but like why
are you why are you rolling around with
it so my point is just that
so many people have taken up arms in one
form or another like how
how how common is it for
the heavyweight
heavyweight champions and you know
literally everybody that can pick up a
gun to do that is this part of ukrainian
culture or is this again just part of
the course when you get an invasion
no no you you that's a great question
because yeah like i mean if that
happened in britain i i obviously you
know influencers would not be picking up
guns i'm sure you know
joshua stood there with an ak-47 on the
white cliffs of dover
but like you know maybe fury as well
like but but i think most you know
influencers would be kind of hashtagging
themselves and thanks for the support i
doubt you know the militias would form
like that i think the ukrainian culture
is quite specific in that they've been
again it's an amalgamation of all
different people i think that you know
that it's a very very old history i
think it's like 800 a.d the kevin ruse
was like you know that's where kiev kind
of started it's a very old culture
and they've been invaded you know they
weren't occupation they've they've been
well you know they were part of the ussr
for a bit there was um a whole lot more
horrific massacres from the ussr there
was nazi you know the nazis invaded as
well unfortunately there was like a lot
of ukraine collaborators as well with
the nazis so it's just a mad country
with like not mad i don't think all that
mad it's just like a very kind of
i don't know like an interesting culture
of like resistance war
horrible war crimes you know massacres
it's just in their culture and i think
they're at a stage now where they're
just like we already have the basis we
know what's coming so we're not gonna
you know we're not gonna accept it
anymore and i really like ukrainian
people like in general like they're very
kind of stoic but very fun people very
funny very eloquent people i keep seeing
all these idiots like kind of strange
internet people that are like isn't it
isn't it convenient that this guy came
up with this one-liner oh it's clearly
propaganda it's like you've clearly
never been to ukraine because the people
are coming out with that all the time
they're very funny very sharp people
same with russians as well like very
similar culture russians great people i
think it's sad that
the way there's a really disgusting
current happening right now for example
earlier i saw that the glasgow film
festival would cancel two screenings of
two russian films nothing to do with the
kremlin not propaganda like what what
are you doing like why are you
persecuting a normal russian person for
something the government has done you
know i mean look at boris johnson in my
opinion he's horrendous imagine if
people then started saying oh no brits
allowed it you know what i mean you
would be like oh that's unfair you know
so i think you have to look at it like
that but yeah to answer your question i
just think that it's part of their
culture there's a lot of weapons and
they've been at threat for war from a
long time and since 2014 the war in east
ukraine has been active you know people
seem to forget that last year i think
more than 50 ukraine servicemen died on
the front lines now people say oh that's
not a lot but it was meant to be a
ceasefire it's quite a lot you know what
i'm saying um so
you know the media there's this thing
now that oh suddenly people care about
ukraine it's like well only for the last
two months for the last eight years the
media has not been that interested you
know i remember going there making
frozen war you know the frozen conflict
documentaries and people one lad died
the day we were there sort of thing you
know like after we'd left and that but
you know it's just like yeah it's been
an active war and now it's an even
bigger war now it's it's just it's in
their culture and it's you know they're
they're tough people basically you know
who are some of the other celebrities
that i might have missed off that uh
ukrainian people that have joined have
you seen some others i see um i see you
see i
i've seen see
he's not a celebrity but the former
president
um
what's his name
anyway it don't matter the former
president he was in poland i think there
was some kind of dispute between the
current president some kind of theatrics
the current president wanted to arrest
him for something so he was in poland
and he came back but when the war
started he just came back handed his
passport in and was you know filmed on
the streets with a rifle he's quite an
old man maybe that's just for show but
maybe it's not how much truth was there
in those stories around
80 year olds ex servicemen turning up oh
yeah was that true oh yeah i mean yeah
without a doubt i mean that's that's
i've seen a lot of like post-soviet
states just old lads just like right
let's go you know they've done it um
yeah i wouldn't say that that's not true
definitely not how useful they'll be in
a war i don't know you know because
perhaps they're not so mobile but fair
play to them you know they're they're
out there um yeah yeah definitely we
interviewed a 61 year old man at the
training um a week ago
and he was like yeah like he was a
microsoft he worked for microsoft he was
like an i.t engineer and he was like
look i'm learning to you know use a
rifle i'm learning to do this just in
case so there's definitely you know as
much as people don't want it to be true
sometimes
you know there's a lot of very tough
people that are just i think the west
has this weird perception of like
tough people are like rambo and big guys
with tattoos it's like no man like the
most unassuming people i have met like
guerrilla fighters you know if they were
in their normal clothes you would just
you know you wouldn't you wouldn't pass
them in the street you know and it's
these are the people that really come to
come to the battle it's not about being
a big guy it's about you know having
integrity and they want to fight for
something and a lot of people
you know unfortunately it's war but a
lot of people do actually flourish in
that
yeah my friend has a buddy who's a
weightlifter out in ukraine and he's
been sending me some of the
communications that he's had back and
forth just facebook messenger or
whatever this most recent voice note
that he had was maybe the start of this
week and he said
um
they're not letting guys through at the
border so my only goal now is to send my
daughter away somewhere so that she's
safe
and me and my friends are gonna get some
guns and we're gonna fight i'm thinking
that's
he's just some bloke yeah
yesterday or whatever but one week ago
he was just some bloke that had a
daughter and a family and
interests and fears and goals and dreams
for his life and
now
he's
it's like this weird sort of cultural
conscription that's that's gone on that
he's wanted to be a part of or i don't
know i mean maybe you resign yourself to
this fight have you got any idea about
um
what the response has been like to the
restriction of men being able to leave
at the border and how uh
severely that's been enforced
i mean it depends i mean the the first
um
the first day of the invasion the lad
that i was working with the local
journalists the fixer we would call them
you know a field producer whatever um
sergi slipchenko really good lad he's
got two young children and a wife and he
was like right i need to get them out
you know what i mean he's like i'm gonna
go with them you know he's a dad he's
not a fighter which is fine like you
know not everyone has to be he does his
own bit and he was like i'm getting out
and he got out okay you know i know a
lot of men that have got out as well um
there has been footage of people getting
turned back you know there's been all
some really awful footage actually as
well of like uh nigerian and indian
students being told they're not allowed
on the train like ukrainians first and
people saying oh well of course it's
ukrainians first it's like i'm sorry
that's wrong that's wrong you know if
there's someone in your country there's
students they're working there whatever
that's a citizen like you let you treat
them the same you should do i get it war
isn't like that unfortunately and not
everybody can be nice like that but it
doesn't mean you ignore it you know what
i mean it's racism essentially that was
bad um really bad and but yeah there's a
lot of people kind of have got out as
well i'm not sure how true that is to
kind of touch on your other point though
like yeah it's it's
it is really interest that's why i've
always mostly in my career i've been
covering what's called like a regular
warfare so not like you know not armies
on armies but like rebel fighters people
like what what you know is happening in
ukraine people where a war comes to
their doorstep and on monday there were
the postman and on tuesday you know
there were a militant the same thing
happened in syria you know the same
thing happens in palestine the same
thing that happens in afghanistan these
people all have lives these people all
have aspirations dreams they're normal
people um and it's a really weird thing
now i i don't mean this directed at you
at all but there's a weird thing now
where people like oh
oh they're ukrainians wow they were just
not and it's like well yeah that's been
happening you know that's been happening
and half the reason it happens is when
you know
our countries end up bombing somebody
you know and it's like well they were
normal people and now they're a fighter
and they're a terrorist but this one
isn't it's like the one man's freedom
fighter is another man's terrorist right
and you know there's a very
i i'm not trying to be like too tricky
here and i'm sure people will be like oh
what about ism it's not what about ism
it's just it's like you know there's a
very clear different in perception of
what's going on you know i've met rebels
in in kurdistan i met rebels in
palestine that all have you know they do
the same thing we do they play
playstation they see girls you know they
like football the first question you get
from a rebel when they find out you're
from britain is which football team
every single time which football team do
you support you know so it's like it's
it's like yeah um
you know people are normal everywhere
but not just not to take any any
attention away from ukrainian i think it
must be it must be covered and like you
said these are just normal people
unfortunately now a lot of them are
going to die um as fighters or just
civilians that get bombed um and that's
that's the real tragedy you know
where
so obviously ukraine's very heavily
armed whatever it is 22nd most armed
country in the world 44 million people
live there how are these guns where are
these guns are there huge warehouses are
they being distributed by some sort of
central authority or the army helping
with distributing these guns to the
militia and also is there somebody
that's managing the militia in terms of
movements and stuff like that
sort of i mean
again it's you know when war when this
kind of war happened so quickly mass
whole country invaded like a lot of it
goes out the window um i know that
there's footage of you know um
i think like the second day or the third
day so they have what's called the
territorial defense which is what i was
filming with citizens that have no
military experience mostly that just
again trained by people with military
experience kind of telling them this is
what to do if we get invaded you know
guerrilla movements checkpoints how to
listen to orders you know how to hold a
gun and how to fire it therefore they
were all immediately called up i think
they won actually lad told me yesterday
they were on the street immediately in
kiev a load of them didn't need to be
told they just went right i've got my
training so a lot of people have guns
you know how they have firearms it's not
like america but a lot of people do have
firearms a lot of people have been
buying up firearms before this happened
so they just took their gun immediately
went to the street i think by like day
three there's videos of the military
just turning up and saying anyone that
wants a gun come and get one um which is
maybe not the best idea in the long run
but i guess when you're
you know no one's coming to save them
nato's not gonna help them they know
that you know um i guess you know what
can you do open the back of the truck up
and just literally
grab your magazine grab a rifle
yeah and then the post-war you know era
will be very
interesting to see and a lot of people
say oh that's it's really bad what's
going to happen after but it's like no
one's thinking about that what do they
mean why why is it going to be bad
because you've got like you know loads
of militias all armed currently unified
against russia but when that's done
what's going to happen you know what i
mean they're not just gonna go oh okay
we'll put the guns away probably no i
suppose that you can't just turn
aggression on and off like a switch yeah
and there's gonna be certain factions
that want control of this area because i
don't know 50 of their lads died
fighting there um and women you know
there's women as well fighting and and
then it might be one group that's like
well we don't like your politics we're
gonna kill you now you know it happened
in syria i don't want to compare the two
because people are doing that a little
bit too
um kind of willy-nilly but you know that
did happen in syria a lot of groups once
they chased that one threat
kind of infighting happened you know
it's just natural human behavior you
know and there's there's no reason that
that wouldn't happen in ukraine as well
but again it's like let's let's focus on
what's happening now you know there are
children dying people are running out of
food and no one's coming to help you
know i mean the west is sending weapons
and and stuff like that but not that i'm
i'm not advocating for a big like
large-scale um
like intervention i mean that would be
crazy i think because no doubt that
would cause a much broader war in the
whole of europe which nobody wants but
you know ukrainians have realized that
it's them you know it's all on them we
spoke to a young woman that she just
said like we need to be ready i'm just i
was just editing actually the doc and
she's like we need to be prepared first
before you know and she was like all the
brains are here meaning like the
ukrainians are here already that's
that's what we need to rely on and i
think they understand that um
yeah it's just in terms of like the
mobilization there are there are um
like a central command essentially
they're saying like right this unit out
there this unit there but it gets very
messy you know and a lot of the militias
kind of act autonomously
and it's understandable to a degree if
you hear oh there's soldiers down there
right let's go
soldiers yeah exactly it's not going to
be sophisticated pincer movements with
people stacking up against walls and
stuff like that yeah i'm on
dude i mean this is
it's interesting that you say oh this is
nothing new you know we've seen this a
million times before this is literally
what you specialize in in terms of
reporting but this is the first time
that i've seen you know just
people civilians
band together and try and create some
ad
ad hoc army
that is
mostly self-propelled self-disciplined
self-taught
it's wild
yeah i mean i think
it i think the the difference is less
attention was was put on the others but
i wouldn't say you know a lot of people
saying all the media didn't care when it
happened in syria the immediate media
absolutely cared when it happened in
syria you know i mean there was loads of
reporters there you know several
journalists lost their lives um there
was a lot of media retention not enough
and there's not enough now still but you
know the media definitely did care um
and you know that that's what happened
in syria you know that's what happened
in many different what happened is
happening now in
sudan you know happened in sudan
last year and the year before
what is happening in eritrea it's
happening in you know um no eritrea um
uh a country near there but yeah you
know there's a lot happening all over
the world um but i guess people are just
more focused on this because it is
europe you know i do understand that
people are like why are people so
focused it's like well if you live in
europe and you're just you know you're
an all person going about your life
you've got stuff to do you've got
worries you've got bills kids this that
and the third you you're obviously gonna
be more worried about
the war that's closer to you you know
it's just human nature that's just that
doesn't mean you're a bad person or you
don't care about people from a different
country it's just the way it is you know
and i think
people are trying to do these big you
know
self-aggrandizing tweets and all of that
like oh why doesn't why don't people
don't care about these people there and
it's like look
people care because ukraine is a
four-hour plane
journey away you know and
at the end of the day there has been
some awful things though in the media
like cbs news had some guy on the other
day and was like oh these these are not
these are um
he didn't use the word savages but he
said like these are civilized people
yeah i saw i saw that like what the hell
are you talking about like the middle
east is like just one of the like most
incredible places ever like poetry you
know what i mean like just just
incredible like infrastructure smart
people learning language food as if like
this place was some kind of island where
people didn't exist before so i think
there's a real problem with that people
coming out with idiotic things like oh
these are refugees with blue eyes and
blonde hair like the hell does that
matter you know what i mean like that's
that is it's in my opinion it's
internalized well it's not even
internalized it's mask off racism well
yeah when you're criticizing the nazi
militia and using that in the next
sentence there's like use your brain you
know yeah have you got any idea
how much support
this invasion has from ukrainian public
people
oh no none
i've got a friend i've got a friend
whose family is ukrainian russian
speakers and they're they're happy about
the they see themselves yeah they see
themselves as a part of russia they're
people in the east yeah like the there's
so there's there's a lot of that's true
yeah i should yeah i would say in
ukrainian i don't they don't consider
themselves ukrainian you know but like
so sure like in the east there is a lot
of
you know the the russian-backed
separatist regions there's a lot of
people there i mean the thing is though
that i keep hearing this russian speaker
thing it's they they say oh they they
don't let russian speak everyone speaks
russian in ukraine
so ukrainian is is one language russian
is another yeah and most people speak
both i'd say most people speak russian
yeah yeah like the idea that it's
whether you're whether you're a
separatist or not
whether you're receptive or not yeah
yeah yeah
most people speak russian yeah yeah like
it's you know like it's crazy there's
this idea that oh they hate russian
speakers it's complete myth like utter
myth there was i think to be fair there
was like some ridiculous decree came out
at the very height of the like war when
it started in in 2014 where i think
someone in the government was like we
need to
not allow russian speaking whatever and
then it very quickly was kybosh it was
like don't be ridiculous like don't be
so stupid like and that was done but
that was it you know what i mean like
the idea that russia is on all the signs
you know it's like everybody speaks
russian there um i'd argue that it's
most people's first language you know in
ukraine um they speak a mix as well like
they'll say one sentence in russian one
sentence ukrainian that is not the issue
um the issue is that yes there's a lot
of people in the east that identify as
russian um that's their program that's
up to them no one can tell them they can
but but these russian-backed separatists
in this region i've been there i've been
to that side and there's this idea that
it's some kind of like russian
socialist utopia like it's it's really
not it's it's very grim um it's very
totalitarian there's no like free media
there or anything like that they were
faking loads of on the lead up to this
invasion they were faking all these
insane videos where they're the one that
sticks out specifically they filmed um
like a body in a in a burnt out car but
the skull was all pulled back and you
could literally see the incision like
line in the skull where clearly there'd
been an autopsy on that body already you
know they'd taken it out of the morgue
yeah yeah they taken out of the morgue
um and there was a lot of weird things
going on like that when i was there and
on the russian back separatist side they
basically like faked the shoot out like
there was like there's gonna be a
shootout and like within five minutes
there was
um
suddenly all of the minders that were
with us didn't have their flak jacket
and helmet on despite them telling us
there's going to be a shoot out and then
when we got back we looked at the front
lines where we were and it was like we
weren't even facing the right direction
you know it was very odd so you know
there's a lot of propaganda there not to
say that the ukrainians uh you know
don't do anything like that but
generally it's
the the ukraine
look the aggressor was in the east i
don't you know it's it's not a political
thing to say the ukrainians overthrew
their government there was a revolution
and then russia took crimea annexed it
there was a battle there and then the
separatists rose up and there was a
battle there you know it's it is what it
is um but no i i wouldn't say that
i wouldn't say there's a lot of support
yeah in the east that's a good point in
the east the people that feel that
they're russian and they've i mean
they're only allowed russian tv channels
there you know they can't get ukrainian
tv channels so they've just been fed
like state media for a long time and
they you know and it's up to them if
they want to live in a russian state
sure that's fine but but i would say the
vast majority of people in ukraine are
not for this and and also i'll be honest
as well actually
um another thing that a local reporter
showed me
there was in telegram channels when
russia was putting out all this
propaganda like this fake stuff there
was a lot of people in the donbass
region you know russian-speaking
pro-russian they were commenting and
they were like this is nonsense like we
know it's nonsense russia doesn't care
about us not that they like ukraine but
they're just like russia doesn't care
about they're just using us you know
which is i think accurate you know what
i mean um so there's that you know
people aren't all one entity but
yeah yeah i mean look kids are getting
killed right now and the whole country
is in chaos um and 500 000 more like
people have fled you know i i would say
that any support is drastically
diminishing for the russians how about
in russia in terms of the people that
reject so i've got a guy who's in my
uh locals community and
they posted earlier on this week uh so
while i still have the internet you
never know these days quick update on
what was happening here yesterday in st
petersburg massive anti-war rallies i'm
fine since i'm a fast runner but a lot
of people were arrested peace hoping for
the best
yeah it's really i mean you know i think
there were a thousand people arrested
for just standing in the street
peacefully saying we don't want you to
go to war with ukraine you know there's
i think i'm getting really annoyed about
as well is the media just saying the
russians the russians i get it i get it
it's easy i've said it as well it makes
sense but sometimes you have to put it
into context you know you're talking i
saw a map earlier i think there's like
there's like 20 different anti-war
rallies happening this weekend in russia
you know
russians are very i don't i've never met
a russian i haven't got on with they're
like and i know that's just personal
anecdote whatever but still there are
good people they're lovely people very
cool very good culture the idea that
they're all suddenly just gonna go okay
yeah like let's kill everybody in
ukraine no they're not but i will say
this i think
i think there is more people that are in
favor of the war than is maybe projected
in western media you know the western
media is obviously kind of
this united front you're seeing right
now of like oh the the russians don't
want this the russians don't want this
and it's like yeah a lot don't but a lot
either don't care
or they do want it there's a lot of
pro-putin you know and even if they're
not pro putin they're like russian ultra
nationalists you know um that do want
this to happen so yeah there is there is
an element of that um but it's the same
with any war you know it's just it's
just nobody is no one's a monolith you
know but i i don't know i don't know any
percentages but i would just i would
definitely say there were probably
hundreds of thousands of people in in
russia without a doubt that completely
not not for this i saw i saw a thing in
siberia earlier um people just like you
know pro-ukraine like sorry that we're
invading our government's invading or
whatever you know
this i wanted to talk about the way that
the press the corporate media
social media individuals have been
putting this forward because this is the
first time that i've seen a conflict
that's essentially been that like the
apocalypse has been live streamed by a
tick tock and um
i i mean i've seen from your stuff
popular front i've seen tick tocks of
how to destroy
and drive tanks separate yeah how to
drive if you catch one yeah yeah like
there's some girl in a pair of
balenciagas and a cool added ass pair of
tracky bottoms
in there going so you flick these
switches on and then you press this
button and then you and then there's her
driving along in the tank
so
what would you say
have you seen anything that's
particularly uh unrepresentative or
egregious with regards to corporate
media in terms of what they've been
saying from on the ground because i've
got a lot of friends i've spent a good
bit of time in texas at the moment right
texas is very skeptical
around pretty much everything that comes
out of at least where i am around
corporate media there's a lot of people
that are saying
something doesn't seem to add up with
what we're seeing i'm not convinced that
what's happening on the ground is
actually what's going on here and i
think that the
implied subtext there is that i don't
think that the invasion is as bad or
whatever and it's being blown up i think
generally what this shows is just a
complete distrust like an absolute 100
distrust for whatever you see whether
it's um
a carryover from the last few years
around
hunter biden's laptop story kind of
being pushed down that was to do with
ukraine trump is a russian agent in 2016
and then
so on and so forth so i'm wondering
whether that has contributed a little
bit but certainly
people just do not seem to be
particularly convinced
around what has been put forward by the
press so give me your thoughts on
what we've seen so far and what's been
good and what's been bad
uh
yeah america i think america is its own
beast um i'm going to insult a lot of
americans here but i don't care i think
the problem with americans are they see
themselves at the center of every story
on earth how can we make this about us
so instead of seeing a child bombed and
killed they go how can i make this about
me
oh um
i don't trust this i don't think it's
real well the mother is crying and her
kid is dead so i don't really care if
your brainworms don't allow you to think
this is real and trust me i have a lot
of problems with legacy corporate media
myself having been through it and seen a
lot of weird stuff nothing conspiracy
just like bad behavior whatever but
generally i think people are doing a
pretty good job you know i have friends
out there right now on the ground
dodging bombs and bullets a cameraman
died today he got struck
um
which is a holocaust memorial um and
russia bombed right near there and they
killed a cameraman um so when people are
like i don't believe it i just think
[ __ ] you you know like i because my
friends are there right now you know
what i mean it's very real um is does
someone have an agenda sure everybody on
earth does not interested for me i'm
interested in the people on the ground
you know what i mean i've been getting
equal hate again from americans there
was some weird thread today where
someone was like don't trust jake
hanrahan's reporting because of and it
was all just like weird american radical
politics centrist central
um selfishness you know they're all like
i think this how can i make this about
me and it's it's actually repulsive you
know i was talking to a friend today and
we're speaking about it and we were
calling it like uh timeline support you
know like people oh how can i make this
about me well i'll tweet something about
this it's been the same with every war
it was exactly the same in syria um and
as well in syria syria was exactly the
same like in ukraine in terms of normal
people
you know in added ass track suits doing
the same things i've seen syrians before
this telling people how to use tanks and
armored vehicles it was on instagram
before because tiktok didn't exist um
the the um
the arab spring was was primarily um
kind of broadcast via twitter when
twitter was like really useful because
um a lot of their internet was shut down
by the dictators in their countries and
they went to twitter and they found ways
to bypass the the ban and they just they
just citizens putting everything out on
twitter so really the arab spring was
probably like the first real kind of
social media war in that sense um but
yeah this whole like oh i don't trust
this i don't trust that i don't trust a
lot of things as well but
you're telling me that
you basically you know like if i told
you a secret right now
like it wouldn't be kept you know like
you can't keep a secret between three
people and it must it might be the most
basic thing are you telling me hundreds
of thousands of people from media
organizations all over the world are in
on this doing something fake and not one
of them has exposed it you know it's
nonsense yeah there's a big problem like
you said hunter biden's laptop because
like liberal media was just as bad as a
conservative media for covering their
own ass we just want to project america
media is its own beast you know i don't
think it represents journalism very well
at all but that was because of political
infighting and we must be the ones that
this that and the other it's not because
of some conspiratorial thing it's just
it's just selfishness at every degree so
i think they're all a part of the same
thing i mean you're seeing the same on
the other side fox news are acting like
this isn't a big deal they're scum you
know there are children dying to act
like this is just fake and i just find
it so awful and again it all comes down
to american exceptionalism self-centered
how can we make this about us well we we
don't trust this because of that no one
in ukraine cares if you not believe it
you know what i mean like they're dying
they're fighting so and it's not all
americans definitely not it's just that
american media bubble like most
americans are completely normal and are
like they you know they're fine but i
think that media bubble that's getting
amplified unnecessarily is just actually
sickening and selfish how are people in
ukraine a lot of tick tock you mentioned
telegram a bunch is that one of the
primary modes of communication
yeah yeah telegram is one of the primary
ones um just because
i mean there's less censorship on it you
know i mean jesus i mean my platform
popular front we've got like i think 400
000 followers now and we get centered
all the time you know we i mean when
we're reporting on isis we have to put
an exclamation mark instead of i so like
i
s exclamation mark that shows i mean the
stupid thing about it
it's so
rudimentary like it's such a dumb
solution
you have to do it as well well have you
guys thought about starting up your own
telegram channel so that you can
communicate
stuff have we have it we have one just
in case but essentially the main
broadcast everyone's on instagram not
everybody's on telegram you know what i
mean and to be fair um i actually spoke
to someone at instagram a while ago they
kind of hit me up and were like yeah
you've been unfairly banned there was
reasons there was a certain nationality
didn't like the reporting you know
someone working there decided we
shouldn't show the plight of the kurdish
people so we got we got a lot of bans
and they kind of told me like look i've
kind of put a thing on your account it's
going to be okay now and to be fair it's
been good now like we haven't been
banned you know it's okay yeah yeah so
it really comes down to that we have
been shadow banned um which you know
it's very funny instagram says isn't
true i think there was an investigation
recently that showed it was there were
different rules for verified accounts
stuff like that um
and yeah so there's all that there's
censorship you know but but anyway i
don't want to make it about me but i'm
tempted to i'm doing the american thing
now but to go back to your point yeah
ukrainians are using telegram instagram
twitter you know emotionally uh telegram
i think though um instagram a lot now as
well instagram's like a big one um
luckily facebook are not censoring them
too much what's the sort of stuff that
they're that they're talking about i
mean is this troop movements is this
i've seen a i saw a video of
uh
an image of how to
where to throw molotov cocktails at
russian tanks weak points
vulnerabilities and stuff like that
yeah yeah yeah i think that was actually
made by the government yeah yeah so the
yeah the um the the ukrainian people are
very tech savvy there's a massive like
iit industry there like absolutely
massive my uncle
like two weeks before the war was like
helping set up some it firm there he
worked for an it business and now
they've all had to come back you know
what i mean but there's a massive it itc
kind of vibe there there's like very
there's a lot of hackers like big time
hackers um i saw some hackers that got
into the like i think the russian power
grid you know they were like you know
posting information on that so
everybody's doing their bit people that
don't want to fight with a gun are
fighting there's a massive
cyber war if you want to call it going
on right now which is going largely
undocumented which is understandable
because it's quite hard to understand
and it the main focus is on lives being
lost um and physical force you know
campaigns but
there's a massive like cyber war going
on um there's civilians are like
blocking roads barricades are being put
up you know everybody's doing their bit
and it comes down to that so when
they're sharing stuff it's generally
like it's either like look what's
happened we need to because obviously
that's like one of the most essential
things tell the world about this
otherwise it goes unnoticed and the
other thing is yeah like sharing
techniques um you know like you said
infographics on where to throw the
molotov i'll be honest i don't think
that's it's not that useful that to be
honest i mean you can you can actually
it can be useful but it'd be very hard
to time it you know i saw a video this
may have even been on your on one of
your instagrams yeah of some someone was
in the passenger seat of a car and the
driver or maybe maybe this was from the
driver and they were driving past the
tank and they just had a molotov
cocktail here and just sort of like you
would like like with a tab
you know you'd have finished up yeah
let's finish this and just chucked it
out but i'm pretty sure that they caught
a little bit of their uh yeah like they
said is this the same video is this the
one that's yeah
yeah but that's just
some
bloke or some girl just casually
throwing a molotov cocktail out at a
tank that they're driving past
yeah yeah i mean it's i've seen it
happen
hundreds of times you know in person
like um
a great example is turkey you know like
the way the kids do it there
they'll get like you you'll go they'll
turn up with a hold all you know like a
bag and all the beers that have drank
that week they keep all the bottles and
they're like they're handing them out
handing them out and they line up and
when the military vehicles come it's
like one two three four so like 50
molotovs hit the thing at once that is
useful because
sometimes it hits the right point and it
actually burns out the vehicle there's
videos of like you know russian military
jumping out their vehicle on fire uh
sorry the turkish military in that part
of the world but there's also a lot of
it is more like distraction you know and
it's it wouldn't be very if you're in a
an armored vehicle and you just see
flames everywhere like you're gonna be
like right out i better get out so i
think it's more helpful for like
distraction techniques and you know just
just showing that aggressiveness is
there like you know and i think
that there's a level of like resistance
that needs to be
kind of sustained if they want to if any
guerrilla or rebel force whatever wants
to be successful because they
essentially need to make it a quagmire
for the you know for their enemy and it
just needs to be
i remember in kurdistan they were
digging trenches in the road you know
the the turkish police and military
would come out and just fall into a
ditch in the road and they're like oh
you know like you know the tiniest
things like putting out little things to
pop the tires um you know putting sugar
in in petrol tanks stuff like that you
know it's gonna come to that level of
like rudimentary guerrilla warfare i
think
another thing i think we'll start seeing
which has been quite big in the middle
east um you know like a dji drone right
you know like yeah yeah yeah
so people in the middle middle east have
um worked out how to like hook up uh
like little grenades to it so they can
just fly over your house and be like and
drop it you know what i mean and you'll
be like what's that boom so you know
that was really effective in iraq
because
it was more effective psychologically
don't get me wrong when they landed if
they landed right the isis were putting
more rounds on it actually but when they
landed right obviously people died but
the the sound people would z and people
would just scatter you know what i mean
it's the same thing
it's the same reason as the sniper right
that it's so pervasive you don't know
when it's coming it's it's ambient
anxiety it makes troops move forward
more slowly all that [ __ ]
yeah definitely i i've felt that
personally with like when you hear
there's a sniper around you hear the
crack
it's like where it's so horrible you
know even a mortar like a mortar round
is so indiscriminate really and you just
sit there and it's like
you just wait you know obviously i'm not
a fighter i'm just go i just get down so
you just hear that it's like
and then you wait and then it lands
somewhere you know and that is
horrible and yeah a lot of that is
psychological you know what i mean
because eventually that wears people
down and i think if russia really plans
to occupy cities
i good luck about no good luck to them
you know definitely not but i think
that's going to be a real real pain for
them and a lot of
a lot of these soldiers man even the
russian soldiers look they chose to
enlist well some of them are conscripts
but i've seen there was footage earlier
of like they caught a russian soldier
he's like 18 years old he looks like a
kid um and they let him call his mom you
know the ukrainians caught him they let
him call his mom and he's drinking tea
and he starts crying you know he you can
just tell he's like what am i doing here
sort of thing you know not not to say
that there isn't some really nasty you
know special forces that are killing
people right now but i'm just saying
like a lot of the troops there are just
just kids you know um and they'll
they'll get to a point where they just
get demoralized you know i think already
i've heard that a lot of them are
a little bit demoralized already because
i think they're like
i mean kadyrov um the kind of i don't
want to call him a chechen leader but
the the figurehead of the putin put into
chechnya he sent a load of chechen
forces to fight ukraine and he like the
next day he was on on video call or
something like he does like instagram
lives or something in his pride of boots
and he was like uh oh i didn't know the
ukrainians had so many weapons you know
and it's like you can tell just from
that phrase that i think he's a bit like
oh jesus you know like i think they've
been sold something that they didn't
expect it's so strange i've never really
thought about this before with war that
um
i think maybe because thinking about
world war one and world war ii it was
pretty apparent that most people that
went to war backed the idea of what they
were fighting for you know you didn't
want this
fascist totalitarian state to come and
kill all of the jews and try and turn it
into the thousand year reich
um but now you have
much more transparency around
information you know for the first time
well maybe not for the first time ever
again this is like me stepping into your
world which has been going on for far
longer than like the last week but
you have an ability for
um
infantry army guys on the ground
to understand the geopolitical uh
motivations and machinations of why
something's happening yes so you now
actually have the ability for someone to
ideologically be
averse to something that they're
loyalty suggests that they're supposed
to go and do
right why am i fighting you know before
it was you come out and said go there
what are you gonna do in world war one
look at twitter i know
you know um yeah no it's a great point i
think i think as well like you've made a
good point there because i'm talking at
this from like i'm a nerd you know like
i i i like i'm a reporter i'm very
focused on war and conflict obviously
that's my most of my career but i'm also
very interested in the very like minute
detail that's what we do on popular
front we try and go really really
detailed to bring out
make it make more sense to people you
know sometimes people do that in a way
that does the opposite but we try and
make we're like no we go into detail
because then you understand things
better for example you know there's very
specific details like uh when was with
certain fighters that are like a gorilla
movement i found out that a lot of the
kids in the inner city urban guerrilla
movements were carrying an extra pair of
socks in their pocket why because they
put it over their trainers because
they're all messed up so when the
military are filming them often they
would line them all up afterwards and
look at their trainers they're like
right this guy this guy this guy so
people carrying extra pairs of trainers
they're putting socks over their
trainers you know very rudimentary but
very smart way of like hiding from you
know from from the military so it's like
for me i'm very focused i know that but
you're exactly right like most people
why should they they don't have the time
or they're not they're interested in it
it's like yeah no you're right it's like
this idea that oh why are people
surprised yeah of course they're
surprised you know of course because
it's more in focus now um
but yeah that's a great point yeah it's
like a lot of russians obviously
russians are very educated country as
well you know a lot of soldiers must
just be like jesus christ you know like
there is no way that like every russian
soldier is some kind of putin loyalist
it just of course not you know the same
way a lot of the militias that are now
fighting for ukraine are not government
loyalists you know like like i said
earlier there's an anti-fascist group
there's a group of anarchists that i
actually filmed the documentary with a
few years back
what they did in ukraine was they go
about like beating up nazis because like
you know there's a nazi street scene
there so the anarchists would go and
just beat them up and stuff like that
now they're like okay there's a russian
threat we're gonna we're armed up we're
gonna fight all these idiots on the
internet like oh what's so called
anarchist fighting for the government
they're like no we're not fighting for
the government we're fighting for our
right to exist when that fight when that
threat is gone then we'll go back to
like working out how we can live in this
environment but right now they're aware
some of them are actually like russian
dissidents that have been imprisoned in
russia and came to ukraine they're very
aware what's going to happen to them
if russia does take the whole country so
they're saying no you know we're
fighting again it comes down to this
thing of some like
absolute like political esoteric nerd on
twitter has an opinion and it's like you
don't know what it's like out there you
know these lads are just like all right
they're one of the lad the anarchist
lads the day they invaded i was like
like what are you doing he's like i've
got a gun and i'm in a taxi i'm going to
enlist right now like no no no question
you know and he's i'm not fighting for
the state i'm fighting for my people but
for you know like i feel like that is in
britain i don't like the state i'm
anti-monarchy um and i despise the the
conservative power and i also don't like
the others as well but if a war came
here i'd think well if i don't know if i
would i don't know if i'd be brave
enough but i think well am i going to
fight for the state or the queen no i'm
going to fight for my neighbors right to
be safe you know and britain is more
than the government or the media
right what the
state and the monarchy and your
leadership and the flag they're all just
uh distillations of what it means to be
a part of the country and it arises in
different ways right whether it be state
whether it be monarchy whether it be
nationalism uh but yeah i i think that
that makes sense to me it's not hard to
understand right i don't know why people
find it so hard to understand like
people are like oh what there's
anti-fascists fighting and there's also
fascist battalions it's like yeah they
don't like each other they just both
have a threat coming to them for
different reasons i mean you know they
dislike the people trying to kill them
more than the people that they're
ideologically opposed right they can go
right let's the thing is in war a lot of
realists really find their place in the
world because they're smart and they go
right put that on the brake for a second
here's the immediate threat you know if
someone's coming out with you at you
with a knife and then another guy is
coming at you with the fists you're
probably going to want to take the guy
with a knife up first you know then
you'll deal with this lad with the you
know whatever because the guy with the
knife is probably going to kill you you
know what i mean so it's it's like not
not to say that the the the fascist
threat is not as dangerous but it's
dangerous in a different way it's not as
immediate right now and and it's also a
lot smaller you're talking about like a
whole country invading you versus
a couple of thousand people you know
what i mean um so yeah it's it i don't
find it hard to understand um the same
way that you know um in my family we
have i have people that are like black
black british they call themselves a
racist would find that really hard to
understand and it's like well yeah
because you're a scumbag you're a racist
you know what i mean it's like that's
hard for you to understand but there's a
lot of people that it's obviously not
hard to understand it's not just yours
your flag you know you anarchists in
ukraine are not fighting for their flag
you know they don't even have a
ukrainian flag they've got an anarchist
they're fighting for their people for
their neighbor and for their right to
exist freely in the land that they were
born and raised on most of them and i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that i'm sure a lot of people do who
cares you know these people are under
threat right now and people's kind of
political takes not important to them
nor should they be what should we expect
do you think over the next few weeks
jesus man i i
every day is something crazy like you
know like just before we came on
like i just sort of just chatting to my
pal there and he was like just heard a
boom like right near to where we are
like in a hotel area it's near an ibis
you know like a hotel
there is this kind of long gone is the
the era of like reporters being able to
be like oh and this hotel is the safe
one
them their rules are gone um i mean they
barely existed anyway
but
not that i mean who cares if the report
is not that important compared to the
people but my point is like all i think
all all bets are off sort of thing you
know um
right now the russians have have control
over like chernobyl basically or at
least they're they're they're very close
and they did have it controlled for a
while
uh today they moved in close to what is
i think europe's largest nuclear power
plant not though i'm not saying we're
gonna get nukes nothing like that's
gonna happen but i'm just saying like
accidental destruction of that
infrastructure could be very bad for a
lot of people you know i just think that
the after the kind of shock effect of
just that level of fighting is going to
be really bad they i saw a video last
night it's what's called a mlrs fire
it's like multiple launch rocket system
and it's just like
like you know like constant barrage of
rockets completely indiscriminate who
knows what that's gonna hit you know
what i mean i mean doing that kind of
stuff in chernobyl or around this this
plan it's just so dangerous
i think we're gonna see
serious serious civilian casualties i i
don't want to predict anything but
i think i think right now it's like you
know i think 130 136 i think the exact
number is but obviously that's hard to
exactly qualify but i think we're going
to see that triple you know without a
doubt if it carries on at this speed
we're going to see that triple i think
there's peace talks tomorrow you know
talk of a ceasefire but generally
like the last ceasefire talks was last
week
and it was russia just used it as like a
troop rotation you know um and they'll
do the same so
i think i think the west doesn't really
i think the west has had a real shock
here it's like finally i think they now
realize like oh
putin is not playing our game like he
hasn't been you know and and
i don't want to give any credit to putin
but he you know he's been saying for a
long time like oh if nato moves this way
then we will do something and it's like
now he has i i think that conversation
is now actually irrelevant like i said
people are dying and there's a war on
and that's not going to reverse um but
yeah it's like i don't know i just think
that this was a long time coming really
but again i was naive like i said i
didn't think it was going to happen the
way it did but it was coming sort of
thing you know what i mean you do think
love
sorry uh kiev's gonna fall uh yeah
i just can't see how it won't you know
unless there's a ceasefire agreement uh
which i just think is not gonna happen
it just they're they're making real
incursions they're in the like the
oblast now which is like a borough you
know what i mean kiev blast is like the
borough of kiev you know what i'm saying
so
they're on the outskirts essentially of
kiev they're not in the city center yet
but they're not far you know i think
they're like
five kilometers
you know well less than that you know so
they're not far away um i i just don't
see why they would stop unless they just
realize how bad that would be for them
due to guerrilla conflict but i don't
know but they're gonna go through that
and then what's next what goes next
after
kia i know i i who knows you know i mean
right now if you look at the country
there's a pincer movement kind of
forming so they're like in the south i
think odessa
forgive me if i'm getting these wrong
i've looked at so many maps but they're
in like odessa they're coming in from
the east as well
over the danipa river in the north um
and like around kind of surround slowly
coming around you know like a crescent
yeah um and they're also a bomb siren
when bomb siren went off today in la vie
which is very far west you know and and
belarus is is talking about they're
going to come from there's a little
breakaway region in belarus called uh
sorry in moldova called transnistria
which is like some weird region that
russia controls and has done for for a
decade now i think um
and they they can stage troops from
there you know to to finish the pinter
off to make it whole
i'm no military strategist by any means
at all but just looking at the maps it's
like if that's even remotely accurate
they're going to end up surrounded you
know there's not a lot of ukraine left
right there's ukraine ukraine
yeah there's not a lot of border well i
mean the ukrainians have control over
most of countries still but yeah there's
not a lot of borders left that are not
having
movements coming however when you see
these maps i should i should say this as
well i'm kind of kind of going to go
back on myself a little bit now when you
see these maps and it shows a pincer
that's not them lines are not that's not
how the lines are you know what i mean
there's not like
every inch is one troop you know what i
mean there might be five miles with no
troops like the other day um
russia tried to form a pincer movement i
think around hakeev
and you know there was an area where
there weren't enough troops there or for
whatever reason and the ukraine just
blasted through surrounded them you know
and that they came away through it's
very fluid
it's kind of a misnomer to say front
line because it's never really a line
you know what i'm saying um it's not
like trench warfare anymore no it's very
nice
it's very spread out now yeah like for
the last eight years in the east or at
least the last six years when it was
more in a ceasefire it was just trench
warfare like it was very weird primitive
like world war ii vibe actually it was
very odd there and yeah like every so
often they call it like a creeping
movement you know they take a kilometer
you know and then the kilometer would go
but now it's like yeah it's all spread
out it's like
it's like you know if you pour a bottle
of water down it just spreads everywhere
you know what i mean and then if you
wipe it whatever it goes back and forth
it's like that it's it's fluid
um
but i just can't see that putin's gonna
what's he he's not gonna start this and
lose face i think that's the the problem
it's like he's not a guy that wants to
lose face he's like 70 this year he's
getting old he wants his legacy you know
i think he's going to get it in his mind
whether whether he has to you know just
kill everybody or not he said i think he
said the other day like what's the point
of a world without russia or something
kind of you know inferring that like
i don't know like we'll just wipe
everybody out i think lavrov is kind of
second in command was talking about
nuclear stuff again the other day
putin two weeks ago was in france saying
um
basically like if you dare trigger
article five of nato like he mentioned i
can't remember the exact word so i don't
want to quote it but he basically
inferred like we will
use a nuclear weapon whether they will
or not it was something like was it a
force and counter attack the likes of
which the world was never seen yeah yeah
i mean that's very trumpian i guess to
say that but right but it's putin yeah
yeah unfortunately
yeah it's worrying actually it is i
don't want to like alarm anyone i don't
think you know i keep a lot of friends i
have around there are like ring me up
like it's worldwide three hours no no
relax it's nice it's not that like you
don't worry like we're not gonna get
bombed in in like the midlands or
whatever but there is like a genuine i
think reason to pay a bit more attention
now because it's like okay this could
this could spiral out of control quite
quick you know how would you spiral out
of control
well yeah right how that's a good
question because
when nobody really knows but for example
the other day kierstama was kind of
saying oh we're going to talk about a
no-fly zone
like i i really sympathize with
ukrainians but if britain starts
implementing their no-fly zone what
they're going to do shoot down a russian
jet
great then we're then we're in war you
know what i'm saying it's like that's no
like you know i'm sorry but no like
that's not a good idea um
and not to say that you know
what can you do you know what i mean
this is
who does trigonometry is uh russian
ukrainian by birth and uh
anyone that wants to get a good primer
um who unders from somebody who
understands the background of this go
and check that out i'll link it in the
show notes below
and um
one of the things that he said was
you've got a world where people have
been making for a very very long time a
lot of war with words and there's been a
lot of threats
um
incentives disincentives ways to try and
push people back uh and a lot of it's
been
bluffs
well you don't know whether you that if
you try and call it whether that
person's going to put their chips down
on the table or not but
when push comes to shove somebody
basically asked him in the live chat at
what point is
the west going to step in and he said
okay so let's say that all of ukraine
does fall
when are you going to send british troop
when you happy you when are you happy to
go and fight are you happy to go and
fight when they invade romania or what
about estonia or what about you know
just pick the line is it germany is it
france like pick the line where is it at
which point do you want to put people on
the ground yeah saying you don't get to
go any further is it
kiev is it love is it you know
it's yeah i mean it's
what like i mean i wouldn't want to be a
politician right now i wouldn't want to
be a politician ever but but yeah it's
like what do they what do they do you
know i don't want you know they don't
want dragging like brits into or anybody
you know and you're dragging them into a
war but yeah it's like what if the war
comes to us first you know it's like
again i don't think that will happen but
i didn't think this was going to happen
you know so
you have to be very careful because i
don't want to be alarmist because
i i think i really think that
it would definitely i do think
negotiations after russia has had or i
shouldn't say russia after putin has had
his kind of fill of blood you know i
think i think that it would it just
wouldn't really make sense for them to
what are they gonna do trigger trigger
nato and then they've got like all of
like what 27 countries or some rest of
the world like you know that really will
be a world war that actually will be
it's like are they going to do that
maybe maybe they will but i don't know i
i really hope not um
i think that i think the problem is
though it's like you said it's all words
right now in it and it's like we got to
remember as well let's scale it back
we're one week into this invasion it
feels like a lot longer because of the
constant media retention which is
completely relevant and warranted but
let's just like calm down a bit i think
like let's relax don't worry there's not
gonna be a world war hopefully i mean
you you'll wear this when we're when
we're at work
but i i don't well maybe there will be
but you know i think
that's that's probably a long way off
you know i hope so i mean jesus christ
but if they do take all of ukraine which
you know they're going to try it's not
like they can then i mean they only have
a certain amount of soldiers you know
like
they're gonna they're gonna do that but
they're gonna be bogged down in a war
for a long time in ukraine
my thought is maybe it's useful for
russia to have a long sustained war in
europe maybe that's useful for them
maybe that's really
that puts them on a different footing
you know and it's they know that they
know that the west is not going to start
attacking them in ukraine you know what
i mean so i think that hopefully you
know this i feel bad to say this to the
ukrainians because obviously it's bad
for them but like hopefully it just
stops there um but yeah is there an
element of this where it's useful
again
trying to be as sensitive as possible to
the fact that there's hundreds of people
dying and the country being invaded
is it in one way
useful for the west
to finally see that putin is prepared to
put his money or his guns where his
mouth is uh and that this could be a
little bit like an inoculation
against
thinking that he is all just words and
then
perhaps upscaling our response or our
readiness at least to him
yeah i get your point i mean i i don't
think it's ever useful but i i totally
get what you mean it's like it what it
has been is a wake-up call right you
know it's been a wake-up call i
don't know why it's all of a sudden but
you know this this isn't the first you
know people it is a very big conflict
but what about the balkan wars that was
a massive war in europe you know when
yugoslavia collapsed that went on for
for a long time and it was very brutal
very bloody um you know nato bombed
serbia um got involved there
russia is in a different place right now
as they were back then you know i don't
think that would run really for uh for
for nato to do something like that
anymore um but yeah i think the wake up
call i think europeans
need to realize that war isn't just
something that happens to
people over there that are a different
color to us it's like no i mean firstly
most of was there because of us over
here in health and safety and we we did
whatever and invaded their countries but
it's like yeah now i think a lot of
people are realizing like oh okay that's
that oh right yeah that can happen like
yeah i think we were in this
i don't believe in the concept but
there's this weird um concept of like um
the end of history you know and i think
a lot of people were loading to that
idea that nothing that bad can happen
again here you know and it's like it can
happen here anytime you know like
i don't think i think we got a little
bit too comfortable maybe not that
there's anything wrong with that we
shouldn't we should want to live in
peace and we should feel peaceful but
everybody should you know and i do think
that
i've seen some quite horrific gloating
from countries that i have been at war
um
not to blame them because you don't know
what their life has been like after like
you us like bomb them or whatever you
know what i mean but again it does show
that like yeah they're realizing like
now you lot realize you know what i mean
and it's not even at our doorstep really
yet you know what i'm saying is western
european you know areas are obviously
quite disconnected from from ukraine in
a way so yeah it's like it is a wake-up
call um i saw the other day that like
i think germany said they're gonna put
like a billion into like defense
spending or something like that i could
be wrong but it was a lot of money you
know what i mean and it's like yeah very
clearly
i mean britain
i don't know like brittany i think like
we had some of the lowest um people
signing up to the military the last
couple years like the lowest numbers you
know what i mean and i imagine that you
know britain and other countries if not
not because they're worried that we're
going to get ready by rush or anything
but i guess they there must be people
thinking right now like
okay we need to do something else you
know just just in case what the
ukrainians did what's your plan moving
forward are you going back out there
i do want to but
i'm older now like when i was younger i
was like
tapped
i think i i wasn't like brave i was just
i was i was just like this is my career
i have you know i'm not i'm not from
like a academic or journalistic family
just from a very normal family and i was
like i've got to make my mark i have to
really go all out with this i would go
to any front line you know and i did a
lot of crazy things
not crazy but you know i consider now
like a little bit too risky you know so
now that i'm older i'm like i've got
responsibilities you know my family
needs me um
you know so i am i'll be honest i know
it's selfish but i am starting to think
like do i
am i gonna go back out but i do want to
go back out you know um i i definitely
why i am interested as i mentioned
earlier i'm interested in these like
anti-fascist battalions there's a jewish
battalion you know like i i think that
element of the war is quite
what what my is what my company does
like popular from our organization we
focus on the under-reported stuff you
know what i mean so i think that would
be really valuable for us to do that and
to show the world like hey it's not just
you know far right or it's not just
whatever it's it's all different people
and i think that would be valuable
reporting which it's like i would
consider the risk you know
worth doing
but you have to measure it on like
when you know what i mean like things
are happening so rapidly now i have a
lad that is working me on my team before
he's going out on his own freelance not
for us because i was like no i'm not
sending someone off to that but he's
gone on his own and he just went
straight away and i was like look don't
do it wait a week he's okay but you
don't know what's gonna happen tomorrow
the next day you know like we've just
seen a rocket strike in kiev yesterday
perhaps we didn't think that was gonna
happen or the day before maybe we didn't
think that would happen now it has so i
i think i think i'm going around the
houses here i'm trying to like
justify it to myself
what you're showing is the internal uh
turmoil that you're going through right
the reason that you don't have a strict
answer is because you don't know one i
don't know i think at the very least
i'll go to the polish border and like
film the refugee situation i think
that's important to do
um
i have a lot of i know a lot of people
out there that are really helping
collecting you know like doing a lot um
yeah it's it's uh it's a tricky one man
yeah i don't know i don't know i think
i think for me i think
i just want to wait because not not just
because of the risk but it's like it
would be quite hard to do the story i
want to do right now because it's so
fluid
they're like hey we just formed our unit
they don't want a journal being like oh
give me an interview you know like and
they have quite strict like rules
because you know they are their own unit
but they came under the territorial
defense this kind of you know this
umbrella of like militia forces that the
government has kind of started so they
do have to follow ironically they're
anarchists but you know they're realists
so they have to follow certain rules and
that you know so
i think for everybody's sake it's like
do i need to be there right now probably
not you know what i mean but my mate
who's there now he was like don't come
he was like it's very hard to work um
and it's just not worth it you know so
we'll see but hopefully i mean no matter
what if it go i mean if this goes on for
a year there's no way i'm not going back
out you know what i'm saying but for the
moment i think i'm gonna do what i can
from here and help people out there that
i can you know we raised some money as
well we raised like five grand to to
give to like um civilians
on the front line that need medical aid
um there's a lot of people doing stuff
like that i think that's a good thing to
do you know what i mean
you know i'm a reporter by the end of
that i'm a human being and it's like and
i've done exactly i've done things for
this in other countries as well you know
what i mean not just not just european
countries so i think it's i think that
is probably best efforts are there and
just like showing the world what's
happening as best i can trying to avoid
all the i'm getting so much hate right
now like it's just from everywhere
trying to trying to stay
not unbiased i don't believe in total
objectivity but trying to just be like
here's what's happening this is a clear
thing of happening this is happening and
this is happening
you know people why are you saying that
why are you saying that you're making us
all look far right no i'm not but i'm
not going to ignore the fact that there
was a situation at the border where
africans weren't allowed to cross the
border i'm not going to ignore that i am
not your pr you know a lot of people
don't realize that i am not a press
agent i'm a reporter i'm a journalist
and that's that and then on the other
side you know there's people why are you
showing that there's an anti-fascist
force we don't like them i don't care
it's like this is my job you know oh
you're like you're pro-nato why because
i don't think that a country should come
in and kill children like you know it's
just a lot of that so it's quite
stressful at the minute but it's nothing
compared to what people are on the field
doing you know what i mean doesn't that
show the fact that it's really difficult
for people now after spending so much
time attaching narratives and ideologies
to things because we've got this sort of
completely transparent communication
medium that nothing nothing can be just
a thing nothing can be just an incident
an action everything has to have an
ideology or a narrative or an agenda
attached to it and that's what people
it seems like they're doing
yeah exactly that exactly that and i do
i hate to even moan about it because it
is so unbelievably irrelevant the second
you log out you know what i mean but at
the same time it's relevant in the sense
that where we get all our information is
on the social medias now so it is a i
mean i have people i think people like
messaging me on my personal like
instagram just like you know like you
piece of [ __ ] your scum like it's like
why like you know like some guy the
other day was posting something he's in
like some weird like hyper political
group whatever and he's posting some
like bizarre thing from some kind of
political guy in russia about why it's
okay for them to go and kill everybody
basically and like he just had some like
really issue with me and i had i angry i
was like [ __ ] you and then you messed
your mouth which was like you know what
if you're ever in london let's have a
drink you can call me the cia it's all
good you know what i mean like a lot of
these people are angry online but in
real life firstly a lot of them are not
that brave you know what i mean not that
much never meet a hater in real life man
right you know i'm not saying i'm a
tough guy but certain things that the
golden rule right like you chat [ __ ] get
banged you know i mean like that still
exists and then secondly it's like a lot
of these people are probably not as bad
as they seem they just like you could
probably sit down with them but that the
internet is no longer the place for that
you know what i mean so i i think
advice to myself maybe into other people
is just ignore it i'm just like blocking
blah blah blah because i i don't want to
deal with that [ __ ] man i just want to
do my job you know what i mean um and if
that makes me cia agent a nazi a pro
crib or whatever you know whatever it is
like so be it call me that i don't care
it's fine like it's all good i've been
to the front line and it's like what am
i gonna do be like hey guys
you're risking your life but look what
this guy's saying about you on twitter
like thinking like what
i don't care you know what i mean like
so you have to get perspective you know
what i mean um and these people think
they're so important by going on these
long like you know dialogues and blah
blah and it's like really they're not
they're just it's just the irony is that
a lot of these people that were talking
about like oh
the left liberals or whatever or the
right wing whatever they wanted their
moment of fame they're always talking
about themselves now they're doing
exactly the same thing how can i make
this war about my ideology it's all it's
all the same thing left right up down
it's like
who cares you know we have a saying and
it's kind of corny but we say popular
front is for the people that's not
really politically charged we just mean
like we care about the people on the
ground we care about what they're going
through and we will kind of try and
represent that feeling in our reporting
more than
someone angry on the instagram you know
tell everybody where they can go if they
want to support what you do and when
this when's the film going to come out
as well
don't ask me that oh is the edit is the
editing ugly one the edit is held
because things are changing so rapid you
know but hopefully this weekend you know
hopefully sunday is is like the latest
will that be on the popular front
youtube yeah yeah so so it's youtube.com
popular front all our documentaries are
there we have a podcast as well um
it's it's just search it you know
whatever if you go to our website
popularfront.com you'll find links to
everything and if i can i just want to
say we're completely grassroots we take
no funding from corporations just
because
i've seen it muddy the waters with
things before and i decided when i
launched this i want it to be funded you
know grassroots so we have a patreon you
know subscription service there's a lot
of extra content there patreon.com
popular front and we take donations and
we have we have sponsors but only from
people we know that
don't [ __ ] their workers over you know
that's just a personal kind of position
that we have um so yeah man if people
want to support they want to look us up
just popular front instagram is probably
the best place right now because
everybody seems to be flooding there
that's popular dot front um and yeah man
we're just putting stuff out all the
time we do make mistakes now and then as
everybody does we're human beings we
have a very small team there's like four
of us you know what i mean like constant
um but we're doing our best and we're
double checking things and i think you
know i think we're doing quite well i
appreciate the work that you do man good
luck with
everything it's a great conversation man
like that's really things are a lot of
things i haven't really thought of so i
really appreciate that my pleasure dude
stay safe
cheers mate thank you mom what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace